welcome to episode 120 of film courage
my name is Karin warden hello hello my
name is David Branum
our guests today are the filmmaking duo
behind the spiritual documentary wake-up
about Jonas Elrod a 36 year old man
leading an ordinary life until one day
waking up to a totally new reality
suddenly Jonas was hearing and seeing
angels demons auras and ghosts
wake up follows this fascinating story
as what he likes to say an average guy
who develops an ability to access other
dimensions that many of us are not able
to see physicians gave Jonas a clean
bill of health and were unable to
provide an explanation of why this was
happening as a result
Jonas's life will never be the same
leading him to access unseen information
while living in the reality of a five
sensory society please welcome to film
courage via Skype miss Chloe Crespi and
mr. Jonas
Elrod hello welcome I just want to make
sure we have Joe say hello Jonas boy why
don't we begin with you first off what
is your background and also what
attracted you to photography I dropped
out of college to go to my own makeshift
film school which was basically working
for commercial music video directors in
LA and I did that for a few years and I
sort of realized that photography would
be a really accessible way for me to get
into film eventually no Chloe you know
speaking of sort of your photography you
know how many cameras do you own and and
and a few and if you want to be a
professional photographer do you have to
own your own camera I think so because
you develop a relationship with your
camera I mean event it becomes like an
instrument the more you play it the more
comfortable you are with it so I would
say definitely you should own your own
camera and I have about looking at my
camera closet about five cameras here
how do you decide where you're gonna set
up the camera basically I try and move
around the subject and find the best
angle and just experiment and I think
when when you hit it you know it you
feel it inside it's it's intuition and
then when you do hit it and you know it
does that mean you're all you're gonna
you're gonna sort of stay there for a
longer period of time and make sure you
get the photo you want to get with
photography it's more about moving
constantly for me obviously with video
that the main lesson that was really
hard for me to learn in the beginning
was to stay still and not move around
too much so that they're really
different that way hmm well Jonas let's
let's talk to you for a moment now we
know from the film that you grew up in
what you term a sort of god-fearing part
of Georgia and you went to church as a
youngster what happened from there
small-minded religious background that
was never pushed on me but uh I guess
around nine or ten I just didn't make a
lot of sense so I've always kind of
chased this notion of God or why am I
here and then I gave up about six years
prior to these experiences open enough
for me okay you know and let's go right
to the moment in San Francisco Jonas you
know when you say you know or as you say
the veil dropped what was happening in
your life at that time and and sort of
what was your emotional state well what
had happened was yes everything opened
up for me where I started now that I
know accessing these other realities I
was finishing up my first documentary in
San Francisco and I was labeling tapes
and charging batteries and that's when
everything happened you know the
temperature plummeted and if you see the
film I kind of go in description and
wake up and the core of the room I light
open up and a bunch of spirits started
coming in the room and showing me things
and telling me things and that process
lasted about
hours and then the next morning I
finished up the documentary shoot a
couple days later I came back from New
York really try to process really really
push my boundaries on what the hell is
going on and surely after that I had a
conversation with Chloe mm-hmm okay
we're gonna we're gonna come up on that
in just a moment when when you say you
heard you know not only did you see but
you heard the voices and this went on
for seven hours what were they saying
well I mean the one thing that really
stood out was they showed and told me to
expose what was happening I didn't fully
understand what that meant and the
bureau phrenic it was a lot of the
things I saw was very beautiful and very
warm and some of the stuff I saw was
terrifying
not to mention under the guise that the
fact that I've seen any of this was very
very harmful at times
um and like I said I the next day of
work and I came home in the mess when
really the roof caved in on what does
this mean what the hell is going on I
never had the thought or idea
Wow I'm losing my mind for some reason I
was certain that this was all real but I
wake up Chloe and I definitely take the
steps to make sure that is indeed the
case and if not it would have been a
really short film so that I kind of
looked up on multiple avenues I mean I'm
just trying to imagine myself that the
next day
like you say trying to power through
that workday out it's pretty amazing
that you were able to get yourself up
out of bed into work that you know that
you literally just didn't stay at home
well what's funny is I mean I'm such a
bail nerd I mean I told don't junkie and
you know it you didn't hear the rally
and a change for the heightened special
audio sounds or the music what was so
funny and I to me it was everything was
completely silent and you know I
definitely ran the gamut of emotions to
all those hours between scared nervous
elated to annoyed to you know wherever
the case may be I'm curious too with
these spirits I wonder why they were
wanting you to expose what was happening
do you know do you have an answer do you
know why that they kind of wanted you to
come forth with that I I mean I don't
know I mean I was a documentary
filmmaker before this happened and I've
always this idea why am I here
the may no life has always been a very
strong one for me um but i couldnt
really hazard a guess a why me but i
guess i would say why not
at this point sure you know what i mean
because it gets into a lot of weird
territory i'm not sure i guess maybe i
was up to the fact and this is how it
all worked out yeah that's what i've
heard is that these type of experiences
or you know mediumship or whatever comes
to people that these spirits know will
be open people that they know will
receive it in a way that they can be
willing to share so from that experience
that one night and the following day is
that sense still as strong as it is
today as it was that one day can I talk
about this because you're Chloe has her
own sensibilities as well I don't know
it doesn't seem to be but it's kind of
the idea that I have a trampoline in the
backyard I'm just used to jumping on a
trampoline you know I still see stuff
and have these experiences but it
doesn't seem as strong as when I first
opened okay there's also a thing where
I'm not being and what to pursue to open
these gifts up more than they are I'm
fine with it really the kind of juice
for me was getting me on a spiritual
path and definitely and I say spiritual
quotations but how many understand some
things I've changed for a long time okay
okay we're gonna come back we're gonna
come back to Chloe in just the moment I
said one more question in this regard
Jonas you know cuz one thing we put on
our Facebook page today was the the
quote they or the the statement of the
fact that you have at the beginning of
the movie that 71% of Americans believe
that angels really do exist have you
seen your own angels have you seen the
angels of others well I
be really honest guys have had
misgivings on sayin Angels & Demons that
was my perception and that's totally
what was presented me but what's not
really mentioned is I see other things
that are part of other religions as well
and so I ran out of a review talking
about a big Christian spiritual wake up
movie and that could have been further
for me and Khloe's intent where we were
presenting my humble what have you
around it it's all out there and maybe
because Christianity was something I
grew up with that's why I think for
presenter in that order but I've seen a
lot of things other than just things
associated with Christianity as far as
seeing spirits around people's spirit
guides if you want to call it that I've
seen that absolutely but you know I
don't wake up in the morning and like
little bluebirds and heralds of angels
dancing all around Brooklyn back that's
certainly not the case but at times I
have had peaks none of this okay well
Chloe let's go back to you for a moment
do you remember where and when you met
Jonas yeah I met him outside of a New
York City Building that my friend lived
and worked in and Jonas also worked in
and I would see him out of the building
and I had a feeling I should talk to him
and it took a few weeks I think to like
kind of find an excuse to talk to him
and he just recently had this experience
and somehow he got right to it
and as Jonas mentioned I've had my own
experiences as well and yeah it was it
was off to the races right away Jonas
you said that you you know when the veil
dropped you know you shortly thereafter
went to see Chloe and I guess what you
know and tell her about these
experiences can you tell us about your
decision to roll cameras on this story
of yours and was it sort of a firm
decision no I mean a clear gonna test
this - I don't know how he got a subject
so quick but within moments to speak
more Chloe we went directly there and
then find it out that she had had her
own experiences definitely a level of
trust
because you know things I learned the
thumb-up meditation and chakras in
different dimensions this was in part
for the course of my small uptown
bringing you know where I was raised and
I guess a week or two later I told her
what the spirit had said to me and this
time went on we did get on with him
start filming prior to that I started
filming home interviews with my
girlfriend Mara just so that I could
have the footage draw so we're not
playing remember when and she won the
dry-ice the music we one thing I think
that works about wake up is that it's
brutally honest and authentic and raw
and you know in time we got our
production crew together when we were
off to the races you know Chloe
how could you relate to this story what
were your personal experiences I you
know I don't see things as much or as
often as Jonah's but I've always felt
them since I was a child and had a few
out-of-body experiences as a child as
well and you know I've heard some voices
and and seemed ghost as well so but mine
is more of a sort of intuitive or
feeling than seeing and so you say that
you had a very small production team how
many people on this team it was me and
Chloe or producer steeped in Ski were
quite a long time then we went to
post-production we brought on Chris
Seward he's done a lot of amazing
documentaries and that was the core team
this is a no crash services you know no
50 days you know is literally for the
most part Chloe and I in a rental car
and a camera and just listening to the
guy where to go mm-hmm this is film
courage we broadcast live every Sunday
at 12 p.m. Pacific Standard Time on la
talk radio calm Holly shorts is now one
month away and Karen you have your
outfit already picked out and I always
love this time of year when you when you
get all excited about Holly shorts yeah
it's hard not to be excited I am ready
to go this year's festival features the
work of Kristen Stewart Kate Hudson
Dakota Fanning Rachel Weisz
Jennifer Aniston Woody Harrelson Robin
Wright and talented filmmakers from all
over the world excuse me
so pre cleped I'm excited to do this so
for the latest info on Holly Schwartz
visit Holly Schwartz comm we were on the
line with wake up filmmakers Chloe
Crespi and Jonas Elrod you can order the
DVD or rent the download of their film
right now from their website wake up the
film calm well this question goes out to
both of you so in the beginning you
consult these various experts one of
whom is JZ Knight and there's several
others about 13 of them which of their
messages as to possibly why this was
happening or or what the reason was
behind having an awakening like this
which message did you resonate with for
me it was Llewellyn vaughan-lee I
wouldn't be surprised if Jonas has a
similar answer but he really rocked us
both I mean you see the few people that
made the film but we talked to countless
as well and he he really affected me at
one point I was crying so hard I could
barely hold the camera because so much
truth was coming from him it was it was
just really powerful you know you know
we've had this question come in from
joke and Biagio and and they and they're
asking does the film capture moments
when he seen the entities around him and
and that makes me think of the picture
we see in the film Jonas can you talk
about the picture that we see in the
film the micro print Anna was very
skeptical and so my thinking was I just
got make sure I'm sure
okay you're coming in and out right now
for some reason do you have your radio
on maybe or your I don't yeah okay okay
well let's let's keep trying there Jonas
and we'll see what happens
um so coin I went to Italy to me with
its media
is able to take pictures of these
entities using that software yeah and
something should own up that I've seen
quite a bit for the year or two and just
seeing that capturing up photograph
really the diamond pup I guess mr.
non-consciously Park I think it will
maybe this in my head but uh he got here
and he on film and spend a base on what
that is and to be honest I would rather
be check it out come up with her own
opinion as opposed to say what I wish
that it was doing to stop the earnings
I didn't even photo and how much let's
doing hmm we're hearing some feedback
yeah otherworldly
interference my gun right now as we talk
about the evidence in the film oh we are
we still happy yes okay
Jonas I want to go back just real quick
as far as the the 13 experts or so that
you spoke with during the film which
ones messaged had the most profound
effect on you as well yeah he was
amazing and I'm curious to how did you
choose whom to interview different after
time beauties why don't know I think
we're getting some kind of divine
intervention here I'm wondering if we
can call you back
Jonas on your landline or or a phone the
cell phone we have maybe we'll call you
on the cell that we called you yesterday
because it seems too good Rona can you
come in for a moment you know when you
hear this and and and help us get
reconnected on another line you know I
would love for Khloe I love for you to
take that question as well
sure um do you guys hear feedback with
me as well no you're good okay a lot of
the people were people that I had in my
tired and sort of followed I you know
I've grown up in a pretty spiritual
environment all my life unlike Jonas my
parents are old hippies and so I was
familiar with a lot of the teachers and
others we just found through fate which
we really tried to let lead us a lot
through the process you know for example
we didn't know why but we had the
feeling we should get at a car and drive
we had a few hours to kill we ended up
at a conference and I happened to hear
JZ Knight speaking and she was pretty
powerful so we approached her and
actually we were the first people that
she ever allowed into her school with
cameras so it was pretty amazing
ya know that was um yeah it was really
interesting to see that on the inside
you know in this EP you know just the
the various exercises that that you know
that this camp that everyone goes
through you know the the jay-z yeah
ya know it was really incredible to
watch I was frustrated because I
couldn't participate in anything because
it was filming the whole time but it
they really do change people's lives
there I mean as you can see there are
people that were really profoundly
affected by what she was teaching okay
now Jonas before we try to switch over
here lets us hear what this sound like
at the moment I can you hear me now
oh yeah I guess it does sound pretty
clear but you know I think I think our
guy Ronan's gonna gonna try to call you
on the other number here just just to be
safe and we'll just switch over that'd
be great okay okay all right he's doing
that right now
and as we do that we'll go back to you
Chloe so from being an intuitive person
yourself and and also watching what
Jonas has gone through do you believe
that some people are inherently good and
some are evil or is everyone the same
we're just going through different
levels of experience uh I think we're
going through different levels of
experience I mean that's that's just my
personal opinion
but there is definitely darkness in the
world there's no denying that mm-hmm and
you know you asked Jonas earlier why he
thought these spirits told him to expose
and you know from my perspective in
hindsight just seeing the reaction that
we're getting at these screenings like
literally people are hysterically crying
because this is the first time they've
ever heard it addressed in public and
they've been going through the same
thing so I mean it's sort of it's my
personal belief that really we're going
through a huge transition on the planet
and the the so-called veil is thinning
and people are having these experiences
more and more maybe not exactly like
Jonas but similar ones and hopefully you
know we can make people feel more
comfortable with what's going on with
them mm-hm and in trying to become more
comfortable suppose someone is having
let's say if you want to call them
psychic dreams or they're just so
sensitive that they can feel other's
emotions while they're on the subway or
in public somewhere how do they deal
with that how do they ground themselves
and do they tell others out of fear of
them labeling them crazy Jonas I don't
know if he wants to take that I don't
know if we have them on the line it's
not I'm happy to answer it but okay did
you get the question Jonas or would you
like me to repeat it I did I mean Khloe
gets antolín I get that a lot it's a
tricky one and that was always my
question for the first one Chloe six
months how do I control this what do I
do it just varies from person to person
I mean for me you know half my family
just won't talk about it they won't say
anything because what that does is
threatens their belief system or the the
worse for them would be that something's
wrong with me
so you have to learn to sermon so you
know Chloe and I don't run around to
everyone I looked at it's about these
experiences ironically enough we made a
film all about it but uh I completely
agree with Chloe a lot of people are
having these spontaneous awakenings but
whatever reason I hadn't agree with her
idea that you know things are shifting
as far as being grounded the thing that
really helped me was doing grounded
meditations and just really staying in
my body really filling my feet
now Jonas and the film you say there are
two things you know of for sure that
there is a God and that life does go on
after death you know and these are two
things that I'm not sure most people
would be so sure of you know from your
experience can you put into words what
makes you confident that there is a God
and that there is life after death
living it the second one first well I
have the dubious honor and sometimes it
was definitely I feel like a curse that
I experienced this on a daily basis I
think a lot of us do we just call it
different things and you know people can
feel energy feel spirit and I've just
had a lot of contact reluctantly with I
guess the other stylize so I feel
completely confident that sometimes
angers people I suppose but for whatever
reason I don't have wine painting around
where I I have these experiences which
help guide me on what I now think that
being said my whole paradigm prior to
this had to shatter the so I could
come to this information so it wasn't
this lovey w thing that just showed up
there overnight the hey guess what and I
did a lot of work to try to clear that
out as far as the notion of God you know
I couldn't call on a God for years
because that word had become a funny
word to me that word was always in her
label religion and these experiences
that I was having had nothing to do a
religion they just happened
spontaneously so I sometimes call it
source and once call it God I mean it's
all really the same thing it becomes
kind of ridiculous for both of us to
watch the whole world fighting over a
legend because there are experiences it
shows some different but yeah I mean I
definitely stand behind the statements
but uh you know sometimes rubs people
the wrong way for whatever reasons ya
know I know people are very fearful of
it um and sometimes just for the mere
fact of what you'll be able to find out
about them you know they just get a
little bit scared you're right I mean it
definitely says a lot about other people
and I try not to have any investment of
the reaction to that but that's the
funny thing about this is we all
No if we could just fly it ourselves
down long enough and tap then we we all
will arrive to the same truth there's
nothing special about Chloe knowing this
or experience this for me or anyone else
it's kind of when we take a swagger and
the ownership on it like it's something
special it's it's just as natural as
anything yeah I was looking online about
something called
was it pineal gland activation where if
you just avoided fluoride and had like a
raw food diet that somehow you could
activate this Chloe I'm curious for you
what was it like watching Jonas go
through some of the things he
experienced and did you ever have to
stop the camera
because it was just too much for for
Jonas for yourself
Tamara it was definitely tough at moment
so I mean Jonas and I and Marik grew
very close during the filming process I
mean I was spending the majority of my
time with them so of course if I was
seeing Jonas upset I felt too upset and
I wanted him to feel better and I wanted
to stop it so it was but you know
usually we did keep the camera rolling
we really we tried to keep it as
authentic as we could you know we've had
this question come in from Dennis Peters
dad and he asks with many stories ending
up being fake especially in videos how
much cynicism have you faced well that's
actually a great question I mean look
I'm a fan of catfish and thank you
filming all that you know it is funny I
talk to my grandmother not too long ago
and she doesn't know what to think he's
just like wow you're such a great actor
yeah I was like that I'm not acting
that's this was my life and I
could see her whole face kind of drop I
mean that's gonna come I guess you're in
there there's nothing I can do to
control that nor do I really have an
invest in or all that but if you watch
the film and you put together all the
pieces I think you'd be pretty hard
pressed to think that this has been made
up I mean my friend I in the process of
this all over the process of this Mara
who was I guess skeptic of this film had
her own moment in this so
I don't really put too much energy with
that and to be honest most of the
greater majority response has been
incredibly emotional any people are very
moved and crying and having a release so
we felt pretty confident when we got the
editing room but just the QAS and the
the touring we've done have really been
wonderful confirmation for us Chloe do
you have anything you want to add to
that I mean oh maybe ultimately you know
it doesn't matter to me if people
believe Jonas or not I think you know we
use Jonases story as a foundation to
bring out some larger truths and if just
even one of those truths can affect
people then I feel like my job was done
you know and maybe it has nothing to do
with ghosts you know and on a personal
note you know do some of your longtime
acquaintances and friends and family I
mean do they hold resentment toward you
for for sort of this film and the the
level recognition for for for your
abilities um well people like this has
really shifted my mother quite a bit and
she was definitely far that god-fearing
Christian and just what I've experienced
with this it's not this big fear state
that I sometimes find religion and then
if you watch my father's explanation for
the film it had to come through a
Christian based thing well maybe Jesus
is talking to you you know I can't
really control any of that where it
comes from but the point we're trying to
bring out is not to sell a belief system
or a message or anything it's just
trying to open people up ask questions
and like you were seeing earlier the
random number generator spoke to you you
know I'm sure for some people mark Olson
on the reservation speaks to people or
jz9 her teachings so we're we're not
trying to you know sell a religion or
belief we're really just trying to get
people to start asking those questions
again you know we touched on the random
generator that was before we came on the
air so perhaps for those tuned in we
should we should go into that okay well
I just found it fascinating I'm and
without giving too much away about the
film but there's this random generator
right that is able to kind of gather
sort of the collective
excitement in the air I mean basically
it's it's a project out of Princeton
that I found through Stephen Schwartz
that I thought was absolutely
fascinating and basically they've placed
I believe it's hundreds of random number
generators around the world and they
collect all the data and a random number
generator is just a little machine which
we show you in the film is about the
size of the pack of cigarettes and it
just produces ones and zeroes at a
random rate and basically we know
through science that it will always be
an equal or very close to equal amount
of ones to zeros and these are just
running all the time all over the world
so what they started to find is that
when there were moments where everyone's
attention was focused on a single object
such as our events such as 9/11 or
Princess Diana's funeral that those
random number generators stopped
generating random numbers so basically
the idea is that you know we affect
consciousness through our thought and
that consciousness is more fundamental
than energy yeah you know and also what
the film touches on is is what was it
four hours before 9/11 you know that the
numbers started to go out of pattern
yeah that was really the amazing part to
me as well it's so basically our mass
consciousness knew that this was coming
for hours before they stopped being
random and on some sort of level we
sensed it and it was documented through
these random number generators mm-hmm
you know I think what's interesting
about that as well as some people can
get it there's a heart since of the head
you know and there's been countless
people said they've had feelings or
crematory dreams that something was off
and what's amazing about this the
science is really kind of saying the
same thing that ancient mysticism is
saying that we all have this ability for
whatever reason it comes this way for me
or for you this way but this isn't a
unique thing so to speak and then we all
have it I think some people work with it
and address it and acknowledge it and
some people just say well this can't be
real what compels me about you too in
about this film is you know often what I
find with sort of those that have this
spiritual awakening is they really go
out of their way
- at least I don't know that's my
perception sometimes where they really
go out of their way to sort of preach to
others you know to sort of convert
others and really as we've researched
you - you know we see that that you know
more or less you're just sharing your
story you know you're not out
necessarily to have everyone out there
buy into what you're doing absolutely
and I I would say also that I think
Jonas would agree you know we talked to
so many teachers and you know a lot of
the times we see people around us who
wouldn't consider themselves spiritual
acting in a more spiritual manner than
those who profess to be masters at it so
I think we really quickly learned not to
preach anything and not to judge because
it's not always as clear as it seems and
we certainly don't want to be you know
on the soapbox waving her finger that
was never our intention amen I mean I
think we have enough preachers and
enough people telling us what to think
and what to do so you know that that's
simply what we're doing we're sharing a
story and then we play that we move to a
bigger place where we look at it on a
worldwide spectrum and how this works
what has been your plan to share this
story with the world I know that you
just did an Oprah interview recently we
did we did we're kind of taking the old
roger corman template where we play
South by Southwest and we had a
tremendous response but Khloe and I
worked incredibly hard for years to get
this off the ground and so right now as
opposed to going with the traditional
distribution where you know we're
touring the film and it's been amazing
as the Q&A afterwards hearing other
people's stories hearing their questions
it's been incredibly symbiotic
experience for us
and so we're kind of taking on our own
now as far as DVD distribution or what
beyond words and they get a DVD out for
us and work hell until our own
theatrical distribution and when did the
theatrical run begin for you guys it's
still running buddy I mean we always
knew it's going to be a real grass roots
slow burn movement
and so we're playing hoppin now
California I think in a week I mean
please feel free to check out this on
our side which is a wake up the film
comm and we're gonna continue and
continue to do that to really get the
word out you know and and are you doing
it in a way where as people will sort of
learn about the film and discover the
film and one screen and are you
partnering sort of you know with these
enthusiasts that want to help you screen
it like how are you how are you
selecting the venues as you go about
well different organizations in
different areas that really enjoy the
film I want to help us get it out
unfortunately don't have a spider-man 3
budgets multi-million dollar
advertisements and so we're really
taking on our own and you know it's been
really encouraging and you know more and
more people are coming out more and more
people or really getting into the film
and that just felt like the right thing
for us to do and I understand people can
purchase the film too at wake up the
film calm when we understand that Trudie
Styler Sting's wife is the executive
producer of the film how did she get
involved we managed to get a screener to
her and she really loved it and you know
she has a lot of the same beliefs and is
into the same things and yeah we were
lucky enough to get her on board is that
part of what you're doing is you're
targeting specific people and trying to
get the movie like you know I guess you
know various influencers be people that
have been known to be spiritual as that
that part of how you're spreading word
on this film that that's part of it I
mean it's not like we're looking for
spiritual people I mean I think that
this is a bigger film than that and just
Trudy came on board and if people are
interested or have questions and you
know we're going to a funny time right
now where a lot of people are suffering
and that seems to be one thing to kind
of get people to ask these questions
when things are going great you know you
don't really think of how to stuff and
so we're just we're getting out on our
own kind of that way you know you know
we love I guess one of our influencers
to get behind it but you know beyond
that we're we're doing with those right
kinda load show that were on right now I
know you have a lot of press you can go
to the the website for the film and
there's a lot of interviews there being
a sensitive individual I ask the two of
you are is it ever overwhelming to do
some of this press and have all this
going on and does it ever get to be too
much no I think it's fine I mean we
played some screens and young Washington
I think there were five six hundred
people I mean I get a little for
anything to be high but uh no
everything's been going really good as
far as the tour we're just you know I
think it's both of us we're just really
happy that people are interested and to
me I I can't think of anything else to
be more interested you know when you go
to a restaurant you know people check it
out wonder what time what they're
serving and you know this whole thing
that we're trying to discuss and bring
up to the forefront is something we're
all going to go through and we have a
lot of passion it's both the very
important topic and in this wake up is
is it becoming its own movement slowly
but surely I believe I mean this is you
know it's a slow process but we both get
a lot of emails a lot of inquiries and
you know it's kind of growing its own
rate I still makers I mean there's a
real thing for going on I kind of step
back and let it become its own thing but
that's kind of counter of how this
industry works but uh things have been
going really smoothly so far do you have
any plans to write a book about the
experience and also do you plan to make
a second part of the film becomes a DP
and we're gonna film Chloe's last about
four years I mean she looks much better
on film than I do so if that'll be
helpful but uh we're I think we're just
focused on really launching this any
other plans to really come up and the
idea of being filled again is nothing I
would look forward to it was uh some
people talk about oh your spiritual path
was having those experiences really a
large part of it was looking my own
on camera in the Edit room for 14 months
and really start to learn and grow
that way so that was no day at the beach
but in hindsight it was quite a blessing
and would you be up for that idea Chloe
to turn the cameras around oh god I you
know there's a reason I'm on the other
side of the camera I'm terribly shy but
yes more and more I will say that I'm
trying to open up to being on the other
side of the camera as far as having
Jonas follow me for a year that is a
little daunting I have a lot of respect
for him and allowing us to come into his
life and and mera as well it was really
some deeply personal moments and I think
that's also why people are connecting to
it too it's just there are human moments
or emotional moments and they're real I
know a - you spoke with Stephen a
Schwartz of the cognitive sciences
laboratory and he great gave a great
sort of analogy about this he said that
it's an interesting path that you're on
but he would not define it as sort of
the purpose and maybe I'm not
articulating it properly but he said you
know you might kind of look back on this
experience a year from now and say you
know what yes I have this ability but
what do I do with that experience can
you kind of touch on that well yeah I
mean Stephen nailed it and I didn't know
what the hell he would slime out the
time but you know there's a real danger
when these things open not to really get
lost in it and so if there's a QA is a
lot of people raise their hands I want
to know how they can turn these
abilities on for me I really had to
start working in dispensing with these
experiences because for me it was I was
getting lost in the experience so your
intuitive so what and I'm really at a
place of like that's fine but what does
that really mean and Llewellyn finally
the Sufi mystic really kind of called me
out because I was speaking tagline
language but not really behind it and so
that really helped me shift or realize
the experience is fine but what does
that do for you and that's where I put a
lot of work on trying to clean myself up
and really get closer to the source or
whatever you want to call it as opposed
to being the guy that has these
I mean it really is the kind of quote
Mara from the film so what her meal was
such a wild experience a wild break from
the reality I've known that you know
certainly I was stuck in that moment for
a while but I just don't have a lot of
interest in it just wanted to be
completely Frank I have an interest so
cleaning up and living closer to source
and joke and Biagio are so following up
here and they're asking is there a next
step after touring the movie you know
beyond the film beyond the manual or
books you know do you know what's coming
next
know what they know yeah maybe you can
tell us no I mean that's pretty much the
plan right now is just to keep touring
and doing interviews and it's it's a
slow process you know we're an
independent production and it's just
gonna be a battle of the Wills by the
end of it but where it is spreading and
as Jonas mentioned we are getting more
and more emails from people every week
so it's been really reaffirmed and and
and I think I mean the book thing came
out a couple of times I don't really
have I think everything I needed to say
I said in the film and there's a real
danger in this culture when these
experiences happened people feel like
experts or they feel like some guru guy
and so there's enough books out there
and there's actually some really great
ones if you're interested but you know
we we think the film speaks for itself
and that's probably as far as we're
going to go as far as manufacturing
something believe that everyone has
access this information it just comes in
different ways
I like Chloe's very intuitive and she
builds it that's the same way with my
girlfriend Mara I just think that mines
you know a little different mara made a
really smart comment about the fact
we'll listen if you're born in India and
you're wearing a toga or something this
would be such a different thing for the
fact that you're this kid from a small
town of suburbs a very pasty white guy
that that's very different but like I
said to our experiences of meeting all
these people clarinet planning and
people to have these abilities some
people are still close
the closet we're scared to talk about it
and I don't feel like people approach me
fearful or like wow he knows what I had
for breakfast and Syria they did that's
not what I have or what I do sometimes
information pops in my head and it and I
would really say it's that way for
everybody
I think the Chloe kind now that I think
people are happy that there's some sort
of voice addressing this because when
these open up it can be very hairy
business I mean some people may get
institutionalized by overzealous parents
or put on drugs or scapegoated or you
know where the case may be so we're
hoping that this will give someone over
a platform to see that it's not just me
and it's not as uncommon as one would
think
I think on certain elements that this
thing these experiences are very common
I think a lot of people brush it off
because it doesn't jive with their prior
belief system but that's just my opinion
in regards to the the the nuts and bolts
of the production you know how many
hours were you rolling camera for each
day that you were with him
oh god it depends it you know 4jz night
literally probably you know we would
roll for ten hours a day in all in all
total we shot over 400 hours and I
filmed Jonas for about a year which you
will see marked by all the various
haircuts that for sunglasses I'd say you
probably some longer than that I mean
what I mean I had a heart Bob and the
film that Chloe really had a difficult
one because with documentaries it's
always kind of cardinal role as soon as
you put the camera down lightnings gonna
strike it so she was very grain smart
about keep filming so she may sell for
ten hours and get nothing or don't for
twenty minutes and really get an amazing
moment kind of like when Mara had the
monastery with the unluck you know and
Jonas from your side I mean did you get
to a point I mean not obviously any of
the actors always supposed to be aware
of where the camera is but did you feel
like you you really wanted to capture
certain moments on camera like what was
your approach or you just had that that
confidence that that Chloe was going to
be there for for whatever a moment that
that was special that that needed to be
caught on film
I had the most confidence and respect
for Chloe and you know something
sometimes things would pop up and you
know she would you know andand she catch
it but she was on it but it's just from
doing a documentary my experience was
whenever I put the camera down would be
the most amazing soundbite and also
realizing going in I didn't realize that
film was going to come out the way it
was I thought I would be a chlorophyll
Coast to investigate this stuff and as
time went on and this was the Chloe's
what she means like now this needs to be
about your experience and then we'll
move to bigger places so it was like I
said it was no day at the beach it was
very very hard on both of us but you
know when all is said and done we're
both very happy with how things turned
out and as we wrap up here what's your
message to people that either come up to
you after the screenings or or email you
and and tell you that they have these
feelings or or they've had dreams like
this what's sort of your message to them
yeah I mean I have certain things I'll
tell people but I I'm not trying to
present myself as having the answer or a
message to be real honest I think that
we have enough people telling us what to
think and what to believe all I can do
with confidence is share my story and
what's eventually work for me and you
know everyone's different so I mean I
could say we're all one we're all
connected or any these other things as
millions of other people have said but
until for some people until they
experiences when they're really gonna
know so not to be a wet towel but I
don't really have a message I'm just
trying to share information so there's a
lot of people tagging that anything to
add Chloe
no I mean I think you know there's more
than meets the eye that clearly there's
so much more around us and and people
are starting to open up to that more and
more and hopefully they'll see that
they're not alone and you know I grew up
where this in an environment was just
sort of commonplace I mean when Jonas
came to me about with the idea of the
movie I thought no one would be
interested in watching it just because
to me I was so sheltered in my
environment I thought everyone sort of
had this ability more or less but really
you know I I want people to know that
there
alone and maybe what Jonas sees and what
I feel is reality and what we perceive
as reality is and we don't know but you
know just have to be open and and pay
attention to the signs and keep working
on ourselves we've been speaking with
Chloe Crespi and Jonas Elrod of the film
wake up for more on Chloe and Jonas or
to order the DVD please visit wake up
the film comm Jonas Elrod calm Chloe
Crespi calm and also blog Chloe crust be
calm and Chloe crust be photography on
Facebook yeah we highly recommend each
of you listening find this film you know
discover it and you got you have to see
this you know it's a phenomenal you know
spiritual journey you know and we're
we're we love the film you know Karen
you've already watched it three or four
times sorry
yes so we're grateful that each of you
listening joined us for another edition
of film